positively amazing it's National pasta
month and Carmine's is celebrating in a
big way joining us now is Carmine's
Regional executive chef Michael and Gino
welcome thank you for having us it's so
great to talk to you I love Carmines
it's in the Forum Shops at Caesars and
such great food and if if you didn't
believe me you just got to look at this
spread and for National pasta month you
guys are celebrating in a really big way
yeah Carmine's in the Forum shots past
the month is every month but we're
specializing a couple specials tonight
in October for in-house for catering
pick it up take out more friends six
pounds of pasta three different uh
sauces three different cheeses for 119
it's the best value on the Strip did you
think about that six pounds of pasta so
if you have a big party like eight
people that's enough to feed the entire
table and probably two more meals yeah
exactly like oh so what are the types of
pasta that are included
rigatoni and then we paired it with
three sauces I like The Bolognese with
the rigatoni okay I'm a little uh fresh
ricotta cheese orcheste with the
carbonara and we have some grated uh
pecorino romano and farfalli with pesto
sauce just with a little bit of shredded
mozzarella on top no but you can mix and
match whatever you like this is the
sauce that you say yes I like it the
Oracle I think I like it because it
fills in the little elephant ears they
call it oh it's like a little uh chip
and dip there you go pasta wise I love
it um and then the what's this one
called far Folly farfall yeah okay so
now all of these as a chef I'm sure you
have completely nailed down the time it
takes to cook pasta like I literally
throw spaghetti against the wall to see
if it's ready they're different timing
on different pastas right yeah I would
say the rigatoni probably takes about
eight to ten minutes and the frafali in
their kitchen it's just it's a little
bit denser it takes a little bit longer
10 to 12 minutes on that okay well
that's for a nice perfect Al Dente I
love it I'm so about these pastas but
you have more than just pasta yeah we
have a little bit of everything we also
have gluten-free pasta I didn't bring
any today which is a corn base which is
great um we have a whole grain pasta but
full menu is available every day we have
a 45 ounce porterhouse let's talk about
that Daddy over there can you get that
porterhouse on there because that is
incredible what
to served with so roasted potatoes
peppers and onions one pound of sausage
links uh finished with a little bit of
garlic oil it's a certified Angus beef
cooked to whatever temperature anybody
likes we carve It Off the Bone a little
bit and slice it and if you like seafood
you've got something for for the seafood
lovers out there yeah so it's a one
pound uh Lobster clams muscle shrimp a
little calamari we brought it today
within the white sauce but you can also
get the caramine's red sauce in there
that is the portion size that's the
portion size yeah so needless to say you
could probably share a lot of your dish
dishes yeah I mean four to six people is
great for us and we do have a vegetarian
menu at Carmine so we brought eggplant
parm as our owner says it's nine inches
tall he probably yell at me today and
say it's a little shorter than nine
inches tall but it's a great dish our
lasagna we have salads we want Al
tiramisu but we have we have great
desserts also you do I and they're so
great go check them out for National
pasta month or any month and bring your
entire family because they have got the
goods to serve you so great thank you
for joining us thank you so much